y
[Música]
continúa la inestabilidad política en
afganistán varias personas murieron en
la ciudad de asadabad cuando el talibán
disparó contra los manifestantes que
están en las calles por el día de la
independencia entretanto hambrunas al
exvicepresidente del gobierno afgano y
autoproclamado presidente interino
alienta la resistencia contra el talibán
las autoridades de haití confirmaron que
ya son 2000 189 los muertos tras el
terremoto de magnitud 7.2 que devastó
parte del sur del país mientras crece la
desesperación de los damnificados por
acceder a las ayudas humanitarias en
medio de un llamado a la calma y unidad
por parte del primer ministro ariel en
fin
y en méxico se conocerán los resultados
de la primera votación sindical de al
menos 6.500 trabajadores de general
motors sobre si continúa o no con el
actual acuerdo laboral que mantienen con
la empresa la consulta se enmarca en el
tratado comercial timer entre méxico
estados unidos y canadá
tenemos análisis
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france24 cerro blanco como
siempre un gusto saludarlos comenzamos
en afganistán que hoy conmemora el día
de la independencia que terminó con el
dominio británico los afganos salen a
las calles para movilizarse en contra el
talibán y ondear la bandera como símbolo
de resistencia este jueves las
movilizaciones se han centrado en la
ciudad de asadabad que dejar varios
muertos luego de que los insurgentes
reprimen a los manifestantes con
disparos el ex vicepresidente y
autoproclamado líder de afganistán apoyó
las manifestaciones mientras en el
aeropuerto de kabul continúan las
escenas de pánico y se han reportado
disparos donde miles de afganos tratan
de huir del yugo talibán marina sardiña
nos amplía la información
al día después de las protestas anti
talibán en jalal-abad que culminaron con
tres muertos por disparos decenas de
afganos sacaron la bandera de afganistán
a las calles de assa taba en el día de
la independencia en rechazo al régimen
talibán lo mismo se está replicando en
otras ciudades produciéndose
enfrentamientos con los insurgentes que
dejan varios muertos el autoproclamado
presidente interino del gobierno afgano
lanzó un mensaje de aliento a los
manifestantes expresó mi respeto apoyo y
aprecio por el valiente y patriótico
movimiento del honorable pueblo de mi
país en diferentes lugares para izar la
bandera nacional contra el grupo de
representantes talibanes algunos fueron
martirizados honorablemente de esta
manera saludo a quienes llevan la
bandera nacional y por lo tanto
defienden la dignidad de la nación y el
país con los talibanes patrullando las
calles de la capital en el caótico
aeropuerto de kabul donde al menos 12
personas han muerto desde el pasado
domingo miles de afganos esperan ser
evacuados por los aviones extranjeros
por su parte el presidente de eeuu
señaló en una entrevista con el vice
news las tropas estadounidenses con más
de 4.000 soldados sobre el terreno
podrían permanecer en afa después del 31
de agosto
vamos a hacer todo lo posible para sacar
a todos los estadounidenses ya nuestros
aliados significa eso que las tropas se
quedarán más allá del 31 de agosto si es
necesario
depende de donde nos encontremos y de si
podemos conseguir aumentar estos números
hasta 5 ó 7 mira el día que salgan si
ese es el caso saldrán todos
y es la comunidad internacional apela al
respeto de los derechos de las mujeres
afganas este jueves un funcionario
talibán anunció que las aduanas tendrán
un papel en la administración de los
insurgentes
en pakistán una bomba explotó en medio
de una procesión de musulmanes chiitas
en el centro del país matando al menos a
tres personas e hiriendo a más de 50 el
oficial de la policía de la ciudad
mohammad asad y el líder chiíta qawarsha
fcat confirmaron el atentado los
testigos dijeron que las tensiones son
ahora altas en esa ciudad con chiítas
rechazando el ataque y exigiendo
represalias
vamos ahora al líbano según expertos el
país está viviendo la peor crisis de la
guerra civil donde se llegó a un punto
crítico con hospitales panaderías y
otros servicios esenciales que se han
visto obligados a cerrar o reducir sus
operaciones debido a cortes de energía
derivados a la aguda escasez de
combustible ante esta situación el líder
del grupo chiíta libanés hezbollah
hassan nasrallah anunció que un
cargamento con combustible y otros
materiales saldrán de irán en cuestión
de horas y será el primero en una serie
de envíos para ayudar a paliar esta
grave crisis de carburantes en la nación
que comenzó luego de que el banco
central cortara el subsidio a este
sector por falta de recursos
cambiamos ahora información porque ya
son 2000 189 los muertos tras el
terremoto de magnitud 7.2 que sacudió
haití según la más reciente
actualización de las autoridades locales
mientras siguen llegando la ayuda
humanitaria los hospitales de la zona se
encuentran totalmente colapsados y las
personas que se han quedado sin hogar
cuentan se cuentan por cientos ante el
nuevo estado de convulsión que vive la
nación el primer ministro ariel en ge
hizo un llamado a la unidad y agradeció
a protección civil y a todas las
personas movilizadas ante esta crisis en
informes de rosa pérez masdéu
la impaciencia se transforma en
desesperación a las afueras del
aeropuerto de los cayos la zona más
golpeada por el terremoto del sábado la
lenta llegada de la ayuda humanitaria
convierte las necesidades en
inaplazables no tenemos presidente no
tenemos congresistas no tenemos
senadores nos han abandonado estamos
solo a la espera de dios en la misma
zona en el suroeste del país las morgues
registran cifras de cadáveres sin
precedentes
el terremoto de 2010 no afectó tanto al
sur como esta vez la morgue registramos
algunas muertes pero no tan raras
muertes entre las ruinas a las que se
suman las causadas por el colapso
hospitalario ante la escasez de recursos
médicos las autoridades haitianas
listaron las necesidades concretas para
hacer frente a la urgencia
de
las necesidades sanitarias urgentes que
fueron identificadas por el ministerio
haitiano de salud incluyen la
movilización de personal médico general
y especializado a las zonas afectadas y
obtener medicamentos y suministros
médicos tales como antisépticos prótesis
ortopédicas entre otros también
necesitan apoyo logístico para la
entrega de implementos y el transporte
de los pacientes
el actual primer ministro de haití
prometió una mejor gestión de la ayuda
internacional para no repetir la
cronificación de la tragedia como en
lee el juego y sobre dónde
[Música]
los días que vendrán serán difíciles y
seguramente tristes invito a todos los
ciudadanos a seguir informándose
quiero recordar 5 y 19 sigue presente
woods y wide hemos perdido demasiados
ciudadanos a causa de catástrofes
naturales debemos evitar perder más por
culpa de la pandemia
los fenómenos naturales agravan la
crisis sanitaria a la que se suma la
política tras el asesinato del
presidente yo en el mois quedan en el
aire las elecciones previstas para
noviembre
y justamente tras su paso por haití el
huracán grace de categoría 1 avanza
sobre la península de yucatán y coto y
tocó tierra al sureste de tulum en el
estado mexicano de quintana roo el
fenómeno natural registra vientos
máximos sostenidos de 130 kilómetros por
hora según el servicio nacional de
huracanes de eeuu en su recorrido pero
de la fuerza y se degradará a tormenta
tropical con vientos de hasta 118
kilómetros por hora cerca de la noche de
hoy se internará en las aguas del golfo
de méjico
y precisamente continuamos en ese país
en méxico donde hoy se conocerán los
resultados de la votación sindical de al
menos 6.500 trabajadores de la empresa
estadounidense general motors o sobre si
continúan o no con el actual acuerdo
laboral que mantienen con esta empresa
la votación también podría definir si
hay cambio de sindicato los resultados
podrían marcar un precedente en materia
de derechos laborales en el país la
consulta se enmarca en el tratado
comercial pimec que entró en vigencia
hace un año entre méxico estados unidos
y canadá para ampliar este tema nos
acompaña en este momento juancarlos
baker especializado en temas de
negociaciones comerciales comercio
internacional integración económica
regional y también relaciones exteriores
además consultor y uno de los
negociadores del tratado méxico estados
unidos y canadá team ex ante este l kahn
gracias por acompañarnos en france 24
juan carlos de preguntó qué significa
esta votación para los empleados de la
planta general motors en silao
guanajuato para la empresa también y
para el sindicato
encantado muy buenos días bueno como ya
lo mencionamos tú en el interruptor
efectivamente esta votación viene a
darse como una primera prueba de fuego
de las disciplinas laborales que se
incorporaban dentro de la renovación del
tratado de libre comercio entre méxico
estados unidos y canadá es
representativo por dos razones la
primera porque en eeuu recientemente
existieron críticas muy profundas a las
prácticas sindicales en mexico se les
atribuía a dichas prácticas no solamente
no defender los derechos de los
trabajadores sino además también el
otorgar a méxico una competitividad
artificial al mantener los salarios
artificialmente bajos entonces sin duda
esto creo que viene a ser primero una
reivindicación de ese es la crítica que
siempre se tuvo en estados unidos hacia
méxico y segundo pues bueno yo creo que
también es importante porque en méxico
el año anterior en el 2000 hace dos años
ya en el 2019 entró en vigor una reforma
laboral que estaba es sin duda la más
progresista que se ha incorporado dentro
de nuestro país entonces bueno esto por
una parte viene a ser
una revalidación de los compromisos del
tratado de méxico eeuu canadá con lo que
eso implica para ir nuestra zona
económica y segundo pues bueno ver si la
reforma laboral en méxico también
funciona como se debe ahora juanes está
votación marca un antes y un después en
las diferencias que hay entre el estime
que con respecto al anterior tratado del
tlcan que incluye el nuevo dime que no
tenía el anterior y que tiene también en
tensiones entre méxico y eeuu
bueno sin duda primero estos tenemos que
ya estamos hablando del laboral de
derechos laborales hay otro capítulo
similar pero para cuestiones ambientales
que básicamente tienen los mismos
objetivos el que se cuide el medio
ambiente que no se degrade a través de
las prácticas comerciales hay también un
mayor requerimiento de uso de insumos de
la región reglas de origen en el largo
técnico lo cual implica como recordarás
tú aquellos debates o aquellas críticas
que se abonó el funk que requiere que se
compren más productos de la región y
menos de otras de otras partes creo que
tal vez lo más importante es que a
diferencia del tratado anterior este
nuevo acuerdo incluye una cláusula de
reducción que se ejecutará cada seis
años para ver qué cambios se le tiene
que ser tratado y que se mantenga
vigente por lo que entiendo esto
significa entonces que había un vacío un
vacío en el anterior acuerdo en cuanto a
los derechos de los trabajadores no es
así es correcto entre otros temas como
os acabo de mencionar laboral la
revisión etcétera yo no lo atribuía
necesariamente a que fue algo deliberado
tenemos que recordarle a la audiencia
que el tratado anterior data de 1994
entonces bueno en aquel momento la
concepción del comercio y de los
derechos laborales era diferente e
incluso hay muchas cosas en el tratado
actual que antes simplemente no existían
como el comercio electrónico en 1994 el
internet no sabía todavía magnificado y
es por eso que el nuevo tratado tiene
todos estos nuevos capítulos digamos que
es una actualización en nuestros tiempos
que estamos viviendo
-juan carlos gracias por su tiempo y por
estar con nosotros en france 24 que
tenga usted un feliz resto del día vamos
a eeuu donde el incendio caldera obligó
a más de 11.000 familias en california
de evacuar sus hogares desde el sábado
el fuego totalmente fuera de control de
los bomberos paso haber consumido 2.600
hectáreas a más de 25 mil en tan solo 24
horas siendo uno de los más que afectado
el norte del estado de california el
informe de carolina aló sale o no
una escena que se repite una y otra vez
en california hogares reducidos a
cenizas miles de personas y enfrentan
las secuelas del incendio kaldor uno de
los nuevos focos de preocupación de las
autoridades vientos fuertes y cambiantes
además de una vegetación seca fueron el
combustible perfecto para que la
conflagración se propagara miles de
hectáreas en las montañas al este de
sacramento la capital del estado esto en
un periodo menor a 24 horas habitantes
de una de las comunidades más afectadas
chrysler y flats se encuentran en la
incertidumbre mientras esperan poder
regresar a sus hogares o lo que queda de
ellos
mi hogar era todo era perfecto
he estado allí por 20 años si tengo
suerte tendré un hogar a dónde ir o tal
vez una oportunidad de reconstruir
los bomberos luchan tratando de contener
las llamas de caldo que empezaron a
arder el 14 de agosto este incendio ya
ha consumido más de 21.000 hectáreas es
importante que todos los californianos
entiendan la severidad de cómo las
condiciones climáticas alteran el
ambiente y contribuyen a la expansión de
estos incendios haciéndolos más
complejos y más peligrosos que cualquier
cosa que hemos enfrentado en el pasado
a tan solo 161 kilómetros al norte de
calders se encuentra dixie el segundo
incendio más grande en la historia de
california este solo se ha logrado
controlar en un 33 por ciento ha
consumido unos 1200 hogares y amenaza a
unas 16.000 edificaciones
en colombia a la alcaldía de bogotá se
propuso identificar a toda la población
extranjera que reside en la capital del
país para así crear un comando de
operaciones contra estructuras
criminales que involucren la población
migrante el alcalde de sada claudia
lópez aseguró que las estructuras
criminales migrantes están operando con
un altísimo nivel de violencia y aseguró
que los homicidios recientes de dos
policías metropolitanos fueron cometidos
por venezolanos esto ha generado rechazo
por varias organizaciones de derechos
humanos y también una medida que ha sido
catalogada de xenófoba
tener un comando de policía inmigración
que nos ayude a combatir las estructuras
criminales
de población migrante que
desafortunadamente está haciendo un
factor de inseguridad en nuestra ciudad
estructuras criminales migrantes que
además como desafortunadamente lo hemos
visto están operando con un altísimo
nivel de violencia violencia armada
violencia homicida incluso contra
miembros de nuestra policía hasta aquí
el informativo continua con nosotros
[Música]
frente